with almost 500 sessions and next 2019
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't catch
any tanks talk on Security Command
Center stay tuned because here's the
rewind securing your public cloud
infrastructure is really hard you have
to be aware of possible vulnerabilities
throughout your tech stack all while
preventing detecting and responding to
threats in real time at scale to remedy
this you need a system that can help
track and solve security threats that
system should keep a comprehensive
inventory of all your assets in order to
find possible vulnerabilities and
weaknesses in your architecture it needs
to detect when bad actors are trying to
compromise your systems and take action
to neutralize those problems would it be
nice if there's one central hub where
you could gather all that info so you
can make decisions on what to do next
that's where cloud security command
center comes in cloud SCC is a security
and data risk tool for Google cloud
platform that helps you gather data
identify threats and act on them before
you suffer business damage or loss and
now command center is available to all
Google cloud customers this hub makes
securing your cloud architecture much
easier now you're using Google Cloud
Security tools to help you find what are
potential weak points in your system it
also locates actual activity that's
potentially malicious identifying and
detecting threats for you and cloud SCC
comes with the capabilities to trigger
either single actions or entire
workflows so you can respond to those
threats and vulnerabilities
automatically one of the features I'm
most excited about is the ability to
turn back time after you detect a
vulnerability or a threat you might want
to restore your system back to a
previous known secure state command
center lets you dial back the clock so
you can be a true Timelord and because
cloud security command center isn't just
for Google cloud we also integrate with
partner solutions to help you find
vulnerabilities and threats through
third-party tooling to export data to
those partners you can use the data for
whatever they need and supporting threat
response actions you might need which
aren't built into Google Cloud
all this info can be consumed via the
built-in UI or from the API so you're
not locked into the native security
products that are pre connected to cloud
security command center this means you
can use our tools or the ones you
already know and love either one works
you can make your own tools for
consuming this data we can bring in your
favorites you can holistically get the
benefits of all the different detection
to see a full example this in action
check out the full talk below and you'll
see a demo of how with the specific
tools and partner integrations the cloud
sec has built in you can help secure
your cloud solutions in that demo andy
walks through using the web UI to hone
in on a threat find what instance is it
impacted and take actions to clean up
those vulnerabilities using cloud
functions if you want to get started
today you can head over to the google
cloud marketplace to enable cloud SCC
through our self-serve onboarding right
away you'll be able to use a suite of
tools to start securing and gathering
information about your cloud instances
subscribe to the YouTube channel for
more next rewind content and thanks for
watching
[Music]